pues allá ya se empiezan a ver los
efectos el presidente yo bailé en
reiteró que en la libertad tiene un
precio un precio que ya están empezando
a pagar los ciudadanos estadounidenses
en las estaciones de gasolina global
resaltó que en promedio ha habido un
incremento de 75 centavos por galón en
algunas estaciones de gasolina de
maryland y virginia aquí cerca
washington el galón supera ya los 4
dólares en algunos lugares ha llegado
hasta los 56 dólares por galón y las
quejas de los ciudadanos son muy altas
lo que dijo el presidente de bailén
también en esta intervención es que es
es cierto que los precios de la gasolina
y los precios del petróleo en energía
han crecido después de la invasión de
putin y ucrania pero le pidió a las
empresas privadas que por favor no se
aprovecharan de esta situación para
aumentar los precios de forma exagerada
y que se termine teniendo un efecto
bastante más grande en el ciudadano
estadounidense y también en la inflación
porque más precios altos de la gasolina
y de la energía pues tiene un efecto
directo en la inflación por los altos
costos de transporte de muchos otros
productos y de muchos otros servicios